we are aware of the press reports
alleging that two Russian missiles have
struck a location inside Poland near the
Ukraine border I can tell you that we
don't have any information at this time
to corroborate those reports and are
looking into this further and so when we
do have an update to provide we'll be
sure to do so so as I mentioned uh right
now we are aware of the press reporting
on this we have no information at this
time to corroborate those reports but
again are taking them seriously and
looking into them and so
I will make sure that we provide you
with any updates as soon as we have them
what's going on over there
that landed I am aware of the reports
it would be important for me to comment
on them at this point I am in close
touch with our polish allies and we are
monitoring the situation very closely
what happens if you wind up finding out
these misses were in fact from Russia as
I said we are monitoring the situation
I'm receiving updates regarding
report and very closely in touch with
our polish allies at this time it would
be improved for me to comment further